2700 tonnes c'est la quantité moyenne de
celle utilisée en en hiver par le
département d'indre et loire une masse
conséquente pour un budget qui l'est
tout autant environ 700000 euros hors
charges de personnel en termes de
logistique le conseil général doit gérer
entre la mi novembre et la mi mars 250
agents mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 pour
cette mission et au dépôt de
joué-lès-tours il s'active justement à
remplir une saleuse qui sera prête à
l'emploi si l'état des routes est jugé
dangereux cinq patrouilleurs parcours le
réseau départemental et décide le cas
échéant de déclencher l'intervention dès
lors qu'un phénomène gruissan est
constatée sur les chaussées bien souvent
les interventions sont déclenchés la
nuit vers 3 ou 4 heures du matin c'est
alors 1500 km de routes prioritaires qui
sont traités parmi lesquels les axes qui
convergent vers l'agglomération
tourangelle bien sûr ou encore les
routes empruntées par les transports
scolaires 17 saleuses parcourt le
département pour déverser chacune leurs
six mètres cubes de sel mais efficacité
du sein a ses limites donc il faut
savoir que par températures très basses
en deçà de -7 degrés le sel est
les plus efficaces 1 donc là donc à des
températures supérieures à -7° le sel
agit contre la formation de verglas des
pluies verglaçantes et de phénomènes
glissants au sens large sachant que bien
sûr le seul fait fondre la neige pour
l'heure on se dirigerait plutôt vers un
redoux dans les jours qui viennent il
faudra donc sans doute encore attendre
pour voir le ballet des saleuses et en
nous